you're welcome to come out with me if
you want oh yeah okay during the
performance if you could give some kind
of signal so I know you're thinking of
me rubbing of the stomach in a sexual
way yes well if you're wondering what
that is all about it is apparently
Ellen's birthday wish to have Justin do
that dance move when he performs at the
Super Bowl halftime show I imagine it's
probably a lot of people's wish yes and
if Ellen asks for it should probably get
it
I'm just saying Justin surprised Ellen
who turned 60 today and to celebrate
we're flashing back to her first brush
CT it's a great experience and I'm
looking forward to what's coming next I
don't know what's coming next to me do
you well of course we did Ellen was just
26 and a little-known stand-up comic
when you first better well what becoming
a household babe we still for the future
its DeGeneres why did you not go say
fresh and regenerate because I'm common
folk I know need putting on airs you
know people gonna see through that
they're gonna say there's not a dishonor
II took awhile for Hollywood to notice
her but in 1994 she landed her own
sitcom for ABC I'm Ellen DeGeneres but I
play Ellen Morgan on television for
famous coming-out episode in 1997
featured guest stars like Oprah and
Laura Dern I'm so afraid to tell people
I mean I just Susan I'm gay in 2015 when
I came to the set of a talk show to
present her with our et icon award we
talked about this famous cover of time
the words yep I'm gay which I never said
by the way that was some somebody at
Time magazine that decided that would be
the title so it's a good quote on time
out you never actually said I never said
yep I'm gay oh it wasn't that that
casual for me to go yep I'm gay it was
like it was a really tough thing you
know your whole life you're hiding it
and then suddenly yep I'm gay anyway
y'all I suffered from short-term memory
loss cast us forgetful fish Dory in
Finding Nemo was another life-changing
moment
for Ellen she says this memorable line
sums up her career just keep swimming
just keep swimming just keep swimming
which certainly applies to me and to a
lot of people out there
[Music]